hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the practice festival the
Masters Edition its young sheet of do
the verses the leader of the tournament
vidit who's been leading the tournament
for the entire tournament and now he's
half a point in the lead so I win in the
final round
definitely clinches in first place but
we'll see if Judah has something to say
about that and in the previous round
with it was also completely winning
against navara if you've seen that game
if you haven't to check it out it's the
previous video I uploaded ok I will put
a link to it in the description below it
will be the first thing you see if
you've missed it by any chance really an
intense game so he has well a lot to
recover from the bounce-back in the
final round with the black piece so
let's see how he does Duda with the
white pieces opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 e6 and of course we go
into the Queens gambit declined I have 3
d 5 we have Knight to c3 and Bishop to
b4 the goes in defense Queen to a4 check
this is the most popular line and
nowadays I'm out Knight to c6 III and
black just castles we have Queen back
the sea to the knight is no longer
pinned and rook to e8 we have Bishop
back a bunch of the b2 whoa sorry
Bishop to d2 and now Bishop goes back
not just yet we have a 6 first it's also
the moment the mostly played move today
we have a 3 asking do you want to trade
here or do you want to go back with the
bishop with it decides to save the
bishop bishop back to d6
and here we have a queen size castle h3
is the move that's played here most
often but here do that decides to go for
a queenside castle and it's move that
has been played only twice prior to this
game so not all our theory is known on
it Bishop to d7 continuing development
and now there is one game add that
reaches exact same position where efore
was played in 2004 don't Janko versa
Luther where black was able to win the
game but here we have c5 by Judah it is
a new move so already as of move 11 we
have a completely new game so do they
decide that this is an improvement and
c5 is the engine stop recommendation so
it's hard to say if Duda came up
put it over the board or that he did he
have it prepared probably probably he
had it prepared but who knows but okay
Buster back to f8 and only now
efore saying that it's an improvement on
the game that we just mentioned which
with the inclusion of the c5 move and
okay D captures we have Knight captures
on e4 Knight captures Queen captures and
now Knight to e7 asking asking why do
you maybe want to capture the b7 pawn
but going for the pawn doesn't really do
all that much
the problem isn't a bunch of the c6 or
something like that although you can
play it Bishop to a4 is actually a much
bigger problem because now your rook is
under attack and if you move the rook
let's say play rook to e1 not nice the
c6 and you're in a lot of trouble rook
to e7 will trap the Queen and there
isn't much you can do about this so it's
gonna be it's gonna be a problem you
don't have to lose the Queen you can go
Knight to e5 and then go with the in
tonight characters on d4 but that's all
they're all favors black yeah a lot
so after this 97 of course do die
ignores the pawn with Bishop to d3 Duda
now threatens mate so g6 preventing mate
and now Knight to e5 very useful to have
the night there you can maybe Riemann
over to g4 maybe to f6 or h6 depending
on what black plays with Bishop to c6
now attacking the Queen asking do you
wanna maybe trade your your great Knight
and well you you could do this do the
decides for Queen to f4 instead going
for Queen characters on f7 and here
Knight to f5 saying that G for g4 is not
a problem and this is exactly what do
the play is g4 so now well you could go
for Bishop captures on h1 you don't want
to allow this attack it's just gonna
you're gonna have to give up two pieces
because you cannot allow further
captures here so instead what we did
prepared is Bishop to h6
it will allow him to save his piece
without losing the pawn on f7 and the
problem is that you cannot go to f3 DF 3
square is taken so here Knight captures
and c6 offering a queen trade so now if
Queen characters you can capture on the
8th
so be characters on c6 end now Quinta
efore getting out of the way and here
with it just straight special characters
we have real characters and now night
back to east 7 this is how we did save
the night now it's hard to say if white
will have an attack going on on the
kingside or will it be a successful
attack but the night is coming to d5 and
it will be an excellent square for the
night so here better up the c4 we have
Knight to d5 and now h4 now White's plan
is he wants to push h5 bust open the
position maybe maybe even push f4 double
rooks and the H file and so on so Queen
to f6 and now comes h5 I just continuing
with the attack and now II five a
principled decision by with it when
you're attacked on the Kings side you
want to counter attack in the center and
here hint the b1 if you go for something
like characters captures and captures
you allow rook a to d8 and now after you
move the Queen black can simply
recapture and now after this captures
you will capture with the F pawn so now
any attacks along the H file can be met
with with the simple route e7 and your H
point is nicely guarded and you also
have a very nice past D phone
so after this c5 we have King Tubby one
and now comes route 8 to d8 if you go
for this captures here Duda will very
happily trade Queens here for example
characters captures and captures and now
you have a problem this is a threat just
capturing and winning a pawn you cannot
defend because of Bishop captures an a6
so you could try something like this to
defend it but then just captures
captures or well or F captures and now
rook to e1 and now you have a lot of
weaknesses rook the e6 could be an idea
going after this point this is still
weak this is weak it's just a better
position for for white so instead look 8
to d8 and now comes look to e 2 with
with the the idea that of course if you
capture the pawn then you're getting me
it it captures captures and captures
with the Czech King the g7 and now h6 is
mate so there's that in the position so
Knights to f4 attacking the rook but now
rook the e3 and
a visit a visit repeats with Knight to
d5 so feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the best continuation
for white well I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who decided
to repeat moves with rookie to shame on
you and for those of you who found the
the move that do the place
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy a show its h captures and g6 the
point is you cannot capture here because
if you now capture the f7 point hangs
that's the the beauty of having a bishop
on c4 just captures with checking a
faith now you lose the rook check
captures and now you pick up the the
pawn here let the night here with the
pawn or with the queen doesn't really
matter you're up a piece easily winning
so after H captors and g6 we have h
captures on g6 and now
well again the the advantage of having
the rook on e3 instead of I need to look
to h3 and now the rooks are nicely
doubled here so what do you play here
well we've kinked the f8 here we did
wants to start running away with the
king we have Bishop captures on a6 you
could start the immediate attack would
look to h8 but do that says there's time
for that he just captures a pawn and now
he creates a past a pawn so any any
trades are now definitely favorable for
him and this is always an issue when
playing you always think ok now if my
opponent comes for me I'm gonna maybe be
able to defend maybe he misses something
maybe maybe I can grab a temp tempo here
and there but when he just
cold-bloodedly grabs a pawn and tells
you that you don't have a way of
punishing it is that he can just grab a
pawn that's that's a tough position to
be in and here with it really didn't
want to be down upon he decided to win
back the pawn with Queen captures on f2
rook the e6 would have been better the
King can still try and run away here and
the rook will be very useful in
defending all of the 6th rank however
like I said we did wanted to equalize
material he played Queen captures an f2
and both of them were very long time but
video was much lower on time so here he
played rooked
ev3 rook the f1 is the strongest move
here but it's hard to it's hard to
understand why it seems like it's the
same look everyone in rook to f3 but
it's not room to f3 and black has a very
interesting defense which wouldn't be
possible if rook to f1 was played so as
it's very interesting feel free to pause
the video and try to find this defensive
idea for black while I give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations as it's
not a move you would you would likely
find it with a little low time on the
clock but for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's rook to b8 and
this is this is one defense that
wouldn't be possible if rook to f1 was
played instead because the rook from h3
would still be guarding the c3 square so
here if if captures which is the
strongest move
Black has Knight the c3 check and now
that's the point if rook to f1 was
played this rook would still be an h3
and you would just pick up the night
that's the point why rook to f1 was
stronger but you know who would take
rook to b8 into consideration so king c2
you have to move as the pony's pin
Knight captures on e4 attacks the rook
rook e2 and now Knight g5 and now you
can trade everything rook h8 check King
g7 captures captures and here you will
capture back rook captures an e5 and you
have this position where you most likely
shouldn't trade rooks because you're
down upon so you're either gonna try
something but most likely you're gonna
go Knight to the e6 and continue the
game from there without actually trading
rooks you're down upon what white is
better of course but it is your best bet
so after this rook f3 rook to b8 is
possible however Queen captures on d4
was played by with it but now he allows
Duda this Queen captures on g6 so Queen
captures in g6 was played threatening
Queen captures here with mate so Knight
to f4 blocking the rooks attacked to the
pawn here but now Queen f6 threatening
rook to h8 maid and there's very little
you can do here with it tried Quinta
efore would check but now for the final
time pause the video and try to
the quickest way to win for white well I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding the quickest
way to win like King to a tube you can
just move the king you'll still be
winning but there is this for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
Bishop to d3 and this is what to do the
plate and it was in this position that
with it resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here point is if
you capture with the Queen you lose the
Queen and then you're getting made then
or if you capture with the rook then you
are no longer in check and you are more
than welcome to checkmate your opponent
rook captures and h8 will be made so now
after this Bishop to d3 move visit
resigned and it's it's literally a
terrible a terrible beat for for visit
who was really destroying the tournament
especially that win against ali reza
where he just outplayed him in basically
12 moves and then in the final round his
navara completely beat and then he loses
the game against Novara
and then in the final round he just
didn't he just couldn't muster up the
strength to do everything he can against
Duda and well do they also play the
brilliant game so tough tough break for
vidit and what this means for the final
standings that there are now five people
tied for first place
so visit future Duda Shanklin and David
on Tony Hara all of them have five out
of nine points and they now go into
tiebreaks but as rules state only two
people can go in two tiebreaks
and two people with the best additional
criteria our visit here and ali reza
Felucia so two of them are going to now
play two games which will decide the
winner of the Praxis festival masters
edition we will show both of these games
so stay tuned I will probably show them
tomorrow as today I still have again I
have to play in my own chess club so I
don't know if I will be able to do it
today but if not tomorrow
definitely so so stay tuned for that so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
tough break for vidit and not just this
game but also against Novara
so yeah you know it happens but yeah I
would like to thank Sandeep Benjamin
round nigel beard and martin car park
Hermione
and Joshua Gleason for
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video serie thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the two games we mentioned
from the practice festival continued in
the Morphy saga and continued to check
up on your wonderful suggestions so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend